[Music]
well the golden knights have a pair of
goalies to be proud of the best tandem
in the national hockey league and today
robin leonard who is back with the
knights
is getting closer and closer to plane
which is a good thing because fleury has
been a warrior playing 16 in the last 17
games
but leonard is really close but battling
a concussion
can be very tricky just kept getting
worse so
you know injuries are tough but
concussions are kind of for me
personally it's the it's the toughest
ones to kind of get through because
they're so inconsistent and uh
it goes back and forth so um i'm
really happy i'm doing great right now
and all right and that is great news
doing great right now
is great news you know we talked about
vegas how they just dominated the sharks
team over the last 10 games they played
tonight
we'll see if the knights can make it six
in a row over san jose with a win
let's head out to t-mobile arena where
john treach is standing by
john it is still a rivalry game but
someone once said if it's a one-sided
game and both sides don't compete
it's not really a rivalry it's been so
one-sided over the last 10 games
yeah cool chris all due respect to our
irish brothers and sisters and there
do appear to be a lot of them here in
las vegas especially here tonight at the
golden knights game but
really the luck should be with the
golden knights three years three playoff
appearances in year four well they want
more
and for tonight they want four wins in a
row
credit our group with the streaks
because you're never going to have your
a game over
over three six seven eight games you're
you're going to have some gains there
through those stretches where
you know either your energy is not there
or
you know you're you're mentally fatigued
and especially as you get into the the
meat of the season which
we're in right now the schedule starts
to really catch up on you so you've got
to win different ways
and we love a good theme around here so
how about st patrick's day
limerick because well as you know
shredding the sharks
is fun but the work is far from done
fleury will save with grace reeves will
punch you in your face
and the golden knights will lift the cup
in 2021
that's all i got and celebrate
responsibly reporting live
john treach eight sports now that's a
great jeopardy warm up thank you very
much john appreciate that